[Music]
welcome to the
your journey preparing for a career in
finance hi my name is kirsten moss
i am the dean of admissions and
financial aid at stanford business
school and we really appreciate you
being with us here today
this is a panel that is different from
others that we've done we really just
started panels like this during the
pandemic
where we usually would have a group of
students come and talk about all aspects
of the stanford gsb
now we're really diving much deeper so
i'm looking forward to talking about
specifically your career in finance for
those of you who are interested either
are in finance right now or perhaps are
interested in pivoting and getting your
mba to do that we really want to focus
on what your experience could look like
what the resources are here at the gsb
and and how they could help you in in
the future
so i am delighted today i was able to
bring together four students and usually
we'll have some
some folks in the program some graduates
recently and then later graduates but
today i thought it was really important
given this panel for you to get a taste
of four students who all just graduated
so they're all class of 2021 have made
their decisions on what they want to do
in the world of finance and be able to
share with their recent memory what it
was like to be at the gsb and what
helped them thinking through that
transition and ultimately choosing a
career
there so hopefully that will be fun for
you
let me as well
i'm going to go ahead and start looks
like we have
all right
so today's event we're going to start
with a brief introduction to and really
talk about career outcomes at the gsb
then i'll give you a chance to meet the
panelists then i will throw to our
panelists four or five questions to get
started and then really we want to spend
time answering your questions so if you
put those in the q a there's also an
upvote feature we'll make sure we get to
the ones that are most important to you
and then finally we will wrap at about
55 minutes together
all right so if we just take a moment
because this really is focusing on for
those of you who are interested in
finance where could your gsb journey
take you
and
if you look right now
the top one upon graduation so this was
for the graduating class of 2020 and
this date is on the web if you'd like to
look a little bit more you can see what
our top five industries are with finance
being at the top and within the finance
industry 34 of our students actually
decided to take a career at graduation
15 private equity seven percent in
investment management nine in venture
capital and then we have a mixture of
hedge and investment banking in the
other
coming into our program we actually have
about 20 percent that are in the
investment management private equity vc
arena so you can see over time another
10 of students join them
if you're currently sitting in the
audience and you're in finance right now
what you'll see traditionally is about
two-thirds of the students coming in to
finance who had finance careers decide
to stay in finance and they may switch
in terms of
the arena that they're practicing that
so maybe it's p e w c or um someone may
start their own fun for instance and
then there's about a third of our
students who have finance backgrounds
who decide to go into operating roles
maybe they're doing their own startup or
joining a company so today in our and
selecting our panelists you'll see a
little bit of everything to understand
how all of those different pivots can
happen
and then i wanted to pause about salary
and be very specific in finance i think
our average salary upon graduation is
about 160 000 for finance in particular
the median is 187 000 and i just wrote
you can look on our on data on the web
but in pe that would be about a 200 000
base
k bonus um sign on bonus i'm sorry bonus
for that first year performance expected
and then 43 k in sign in bonus
so that gives you a sense of what how
your compensation might change as you
evolve through the gsb another thing to
note is our students come upon any given
year will work both for their
internships and upon graduation for 445
different organizations and given
stanford's classes only about 400
students you can see that we're our
students are very targeted and where
they want to go and there is just a
plethora of opportunities unlike perhaps
what you might have seen in undergrad
where there are huge feeder companies
that are coming to campus here you
really will have whether it's geography
industry you know or location you'll i
mean geography industry or function
you'll have many many choices
all right so it's time to meet our
panelists we have four today and as i
said we i tried to ensure on the panel
that you'd see lots of different
backgrounds so some um you'll hear
didn't have any finance background and
have now pivoted there others came from
finance and might be taking roles in a
different industry although keeping that
finance strong
or coming from pe and banking perhaps
and going into hedge your search so
we're going to hear a little bit more
about that right now and daniel i'm
going to start with you and i'm going to
ask you to first tell us about your role
before the gsb
why you decided to attend and i'll pause
there because what we find with our
prospects who are coming from finance
oftentimes it's hard to give up the jobs
that they already have so we're going to
hit on that
or or the question that comes up is how
valuable is an mba do i need to do it so
for each of you i'm going to ask you
about your role before the gsb why you
decided to attend stanford and then what
you're going to be doing now and how the
gsb influenced that decision over your
two years
perfect thank you very much person
so i'm danielle i was
born in colombia before the gsb i work
at citigroup in the investment bank in m
a latin america group for two years in
europe and mexico city
and then i moved to colombia to work for
a higher education
startup
uh and while doing that i started a
non-profit uh call mentors for you it's
a career development mentorship program
to help low income college students get
the best jobs in colombia and i was also
an adjunct professor at a local
university of social entrepreneurship
there in colombia
um
i
i came to the gsb uh because well i
wanted to i did a joint degree the mba
mastering education which is a very very
unique
program ideal for anyone that wants to
be
in a business and education role or a
leadership role in an education
institution or
doing a startup in education or
investing in education
uh and and that's uh that's
during the gsb i i was involved in
everything related to education and
investing in investing in
entrepreneurship in education
and i just joined as a partner of an
education focused investment fund and
venture builder called appian education
vendors
awesome and um danielle was there
anything at the gsb that helped you in
particular decide that this was the this
was the ultimate job you wanted to take
sure so i think um
so combat the impact fund i think was uh
that that really really helped me i was
in the education team of the impact fund
and
and um
thanks to that like i learned everything
about kind of early stage pc investing
in education
and thanks to that i i met um
the team at owl ventures which is a tech
dc fund that we're our advisor at the
the
the impact fund and i work with them
like volunteer with them part-time uh
helping them invest in latin america for
these two years so they gave actually it
was the perfect experience to then go
into a more high-tech focus
role
so i think that was one of the best
experiences for my particular
interest great thanks so much um georgie
how about i start with you next your
role before the gsb why you decided to
come and what you're doing now and then
how uh the gsb helped you figure that
out
sure um hi everyone i'm georgie uh
before the gsp i worked for two years in
investment banking at jpmorgan
and then i worked for two years in
private equity at tpg i worked
specifically in tpg growth and the rise
fund which is tbg's social impact fund
i came to stanford uh it's fine i think
back now but i came for a few reasons um
coming out of private equity i
definitely struggled with what kirsten
was talking about of feeling as though
in my current spot i had a number of
attractive opportunities that i wanted
to pursue i knew i loved investing and
from my current role i had opportunities
to continue in private equity or go
directly to work at a hedge fund which
is what i was most interested in
so the decision to you know trade off
between going directly to these great
opportunities versus going to business
school was a tough one for me
um it was solved and not to be too cute
here but really when i got into stanford
um for me i wasn't sure that any
business school would be the right
choice but stanford seemed to me to
really have an x factor that would make
it incredibly impactful both for my
professional life and also my personal
life
professionally because just seeing
examples it's such a small elite
community where i heard time and time
again that by meeting professors or
meeting classmates you know people ended
up pursuing careers they hadn't dreamed
of um you know one example is a
legendary professor mcdonald who you
know through his mentorship and
connecting profess people to the bass
family there you know was sprouted tpg
spo
um
oh gosh and essentially five massive
massive firms and so it just seemed like
a place that was really an accelerator
of connecting talented people and
resources to create a really exciting
new path and so i thought that
yes i want to work at a hedge fund or so
i thought but let me at least go spend
these two years opening opportunities in
case i don't want to do that and then
personally uh stanford just has such a
unique culture i you know i've heard it
referred to as a personal boot camp and
i would definitely second that um i
thought it would be a great place to
really reflect on my experiences and
refine sort of what my strengths and
weaknesses were and what i really wanted
out of
my career so i could make a good choice
coming out of my two years there so that
was why i chose stanford um
after school or now i'm working on
what's called a search fund which is
basically raising money to go out and
buy a business
and in terms of how the gsb influenced
that um the gsb was pivotal
in that uh decision i came into my
second year having done an internship in
investment management at fidelity
thinking for sure i wanted to work in a
hedge fund
by winter quarter i stumbled into a
search fund class never having heard
what a search fund was
um and then meeting those professors
kind of falling into that network uh the
search fund really was born out of
stanford and irv rosbeck um i kind of
fell in love with it and it felt like a
great fit for my both my skills but also
what i really wanted out of a career and
kind of taking risk at this point so um
without stanford i'm not sure if i would
be doing this and so i'm really grateful
for the experience
awesome thank you georgie how about
jessica we turn it over to you
yeah of course um hi nice to meet
everyone um i'm jessica i'm originally
from salvador brazil um
most recently prior to the gsb i was at
palantir um so i worked there in sort of
a myriad of like product management
business development focused
specifically on the government side of
the business so very much not finance
and then before that i worked at a law
firm because once upon a time i thought
i wanted to be a lawyer so also like
really not finance so i i came in um
and was what we uh affectionately called
it the just be the triple b's so i took
base accounting based finance
they i based like i forgot even what the
other class was kind of sad
um so it was like really like did not
know anything coming into the gsb if you
ask me what like an income
statement was i would probably run away
crying so that's just to level that like
how little i knew about finance um
and
now i work in venture capital i work in
early stage venture um invest in seed
through series c although my fund
actually just raised the growth fund so
i'll also do that um coming shortly um
i guess a couple of the things i think
are worth mentioning one um i i think
the gsb was phenomenal in terms of
giving me a financial education so i
feel very confident now
um
with basically anything related to
finance was able i was able to build
upon i had a fantastic
intro to finance class when i first
started the gsb was able to build on top
of that and take a bunch of finance
classes that
further specialize and deepen my
knowledge throughout the gsb
um and i thought i thought the jsp was
just really great at helping me gain
that knowledge there were many like
tutoring opportunities after
after classes so that i could beef up my
knowledge since i was coming in at like
a very low
level of finance knowledge um
in general like all the classmates were
really helpful professors were really
helpful so i would just say particularly
for any one of you who are thinking of
going to a career in finance and kind of
nervous about um
how you're going to do that if you don't
have the experience i i think the end
the mba is really just fantastic for
them the gsb in particular really really
prepared me for for a career in finance
so i think that that's sort of number
one um
and then kristin please remind me of the
other questions yeah you've answered
them um how did you decide to go into
venture capital and was there anything
that particularly helped you in that
yeah so um i i always loved technology
so when i worked at the law firm i
worked in intellectual property um
obviously palantir is very you know i
wasn't really a startup at the time i
joined like very much in the world of
tech and i always thought it was really
interesting um but i i kind of realized
that i didn't necessarily want to do
um be an operator for the long term and
that is like working in startups and i
i just love the idea i love the idea of
helping people and helping people sort
of achieve their dreams and i thought
that working in venture was a way for me
to pair up with a bunch of entrepreneurs
and help them
sort of build great companies and sort
and give my the skills that i have which
is sort of helping people achieve their
potential and having sort of like a
clear and logical mind and like spotting
trends and like helping in that way um
so i thought it was sort of a good fit
for what i was interested in and sort of
the skills i i had and then the skills
that i built at the gsb
and at the gsb i got really involved in
the venture capital club i was the
president of the venture capital club
and
really loved it got to meet with a bunch
of venture funds i think for anyone
going to venture there's
i i personally don't think that there's
another business school that can hold
like a candle to the gsb like you just
see the entire sandhill world venture
funds like coming in and desperate to
meet gsps they all want to know what
your classmates are are starting and
what you're doing and what's what's
happening on campus like it's very it's
a very thriving ecosystem and so
it's kind of like a no-brainer since i i
thought i wanted to do a venture to go
to the gsb and then that very much
proved true once i went to the gsb it
was just like
absolutely the best um the best place i
could have been and um
kind of like had my pick up jobs like
once i graduated and picked this um
fund that i really really loved and
intern over the summer
i guess the other thing i would say that
was really helpful is i have a lot of
classmates from college that went to
other business schools that didn't
necessarily have the best experience
with the career services at the other
schools and i on the other hand like
could sing praises to this there's this
one person called tom who's like the
person for venture capital and at the
gsdn i mean like he would answer my
emails in a minute i would call him like
freaking out before interviews on a
saturday and he would be there and
cheering on me just like really really
incredible people and support so i mean
like have nothing but amazing things to
say about the gsb when it came to that
particularly given i had like no
background no network because i'm
brazilian like really didn't know people
like just you really helped me set me up
well for for going into bc
awesome thank you jessica ishan how
about you
yeah sure so um before business school i
did a smattering of different things i
worked at so really can private equity
out of college
um doing kind of technology buyouts
i left to start my own company which was
uh education marketplace i did that for
two years
and after selling that i
worked at china's largest wealth manager
sourcing growth stage u.s technology
deals so
you know throughout all of those i knew
my passion was technology i had seen
companies at basically every stage from
idea stage to growth stage to
late stage buyout
and
i had actually similar to georgie i had
read this article online i might post it
in the chat
uh
about several
uh gsb investors in the 70s and 80s that
came from jack mcdonald but others too
including an investment group of santa
barbara and i said wow these are these
are some amazing investors
um
they're not as well covered as warren
buffett but in my mind
i wanted to be like them
and they focused on technology and they
had a long-term view of the world and so
that's why i came to gsp i said maybe
i'll have a shot at becoming like them
if i go to this school
and i actually came in with that focus
which i never really felt prior and it
was reaffirmed to me within the first
six months of gsp
mostly through other classmates i think
something that a lot of people don't
talk about
is the breadth of experiences that the
classmates have at gsp
whether that's deep in venture capital
or
whether that's like jessica talentier
and just seeing all aspects of
technology helped me figure out
um that i really wanted to be on the
investment side long term
and um you know basically do that and
this opportunity at citadel i worked
there between first and second year
was kind of the last part of the tech
life cycle that i hadn't explored public
markets
and so i took that up in the summer this
was during covet which was an
interesting uncertain time
and i really enjoyed it uh and there my
logic was very similar to the reason why
i came to gsb which was the people i met
were the smartest people i could find
and also i could
spend a lot of time with them and still
be happy and be myself which i think is
very important
and i found that to be true
during the three months at citadel in
the summer so i've returned and
started here
and i would say the second thing that
you know i probably haven't seen the
benefits of yet but i will soon
or later in life
is a lot of the
non-finance courses at gsp which is a
big reason i came touchy-feely and
interpersonal dynamics and other courses
and i think
in finance sometimes we underestimate
the importance of
teamwork and evaluating people
and even building teams within within
financial organizations
and stanford does an amazing job of that
and i would say that's something not to
dismiss when you're thinking about
stanford in the lens of finance and
probably something people don't talk
about enough
fantastic
thank you ishin um what's what i love
about hearing from all of you is such
different backgrounds and and still
going in different paths but finding
things at the gsb that helped you get
there let's take a um
make a bridge from your last answer ish
and one of the things i did want to ask
was
what was an academic course or
experience that has really helped you or
you think will help you in your current
job or as ishin said in your next steps
and it could be in finance or it could
have been something like touchy-feely
but what pops for you academic course or
experience how about i start back with
you
dania
sure and i want to highlight what what
asian said about the the soft skills
interpersonal aspect
i for me the the most unique experience
of the gsb was being an arbuckle fellow
and for those of you that you don't know
what our bubble fellow it's a it's a
program where you're basically
trained as a as a coach and as a mentor
and then you have the opportunity to
receive coaching and mentorship from
professional coaches throughout the year
and then you become the coach to eight
first years
and basically i just that experience
which was an incredibly
uh
just introspection development of
self-awareness personal development how
i impact others how others impact me
just having that that awareness
um was incredibly i think it's the most
it represents what the gsb is which is
it has just world-class
finance and operations and
entrepreneurship materials with
an experiences and classes but just
combining that with this touchy
feeliness it's incredibly unique and
this is what i think what we need more
in in finance in the industry uh so so i
think that that's the thing that i say
it's just incredible how we could take
an investment class or a search fund
garage which is like that i took with
georgie like that type of class finance
and entrepreneurship and then combined
with more uh you know
touchy-feely herbal fellows like just
this coaching and talent and just having
having that versatility of being able to
go to one side or the other uh the more
logical to a more emotional
and and just being able to adapt to
whatever
person we're dealing with or whatever
situation we have
awesome how about jessica i come back to
you
yeah i i would definitely highlight the
the soft skills classes we have we have
a bunch so in your first year um you do
something called the leadership labs and
you get to interact with fellow
classmates and you get recorded and you
see sort of how you interact in a group
um and then there's touchy-feely class
which is interpersonal dynamics which is
also sort of like a deep dive into
quite literally interpersonal dynamics
and relationships i think that's really
helpful because obviously a career in
finance is
yeah you have to know finance but you
also there's so much about the people
element right like finances is most the
time
even even in hedge funds like you're
still meeting with companies and the
ceos and getting to build relationships
with them but
most most of finances you're investing
in a company you're meeting with
entrepreneurs or you're meeting with a
ceo and you're you're getting to know
people and you're you're in the business
of people and i think that that's
sometimes not um
highlighted by by folks who think about
like how what is going to be your
financial education and so i think that
learning how to how to really interact
well with people is really important um
i think on the more hard skill classes i
think one of the classes that i really
loved because i took this sort of
legendary financial modeling class from
a professor called dimarzo yeah work you
kind of sell your soul to that class for
a quarter but again like i came from
knowing absolutely nothing like again
like i would open an excel sheet and
like come running to the other side and
cry
to
be able to completely model an lbo like
an entire waterfall of dc returns and
feel really confident with that that's i
think some pretty crazy transformation
for sitting three months in the
classroom and in my case over zoom doing
this um so you do really get very well
equipped to go into the career
awesome thank you jessica and i'm
guessing about half of our audience is
in your position of i want to be in
finance and haven't done it so it's
really helpful and just one other
comment before jessica was talking about
base classes when you come in there is a
required curriculum at the gsb and there
are three different levels so for those
of you who haven't seen finance before
you'll go into the base and for those of
you maybe more like georgie's background
who who was it was an eye banking and
private equity you'll go into the very
top level of the finance class because
we want to customize it to what you're
learning is
georgie i'm going to come back to you
one of the things that is very special
about the gsb is all the experiential
classes startup garage interpersonal
dynamics that and you did one of our
newest courses is this startup search
fund and now you're doing a search fund
any highlight you can give the audience
so they understand what it means to do
something experiential and also finance
at this you know bringing both of those
together and i'll say one more thing at
stanford we're not you will read case
studies as a student and you'll
recommend to the protagonist you know if
you write your
a write-up on the case what they should
do but we also want you to be the
protagonist of your own life so we want
to give you the skills to go out and do
things not just read about it and tell
other people what to do so i'd love to
get your insights on how that course
went
yeah that was a fantastic course and i'm
sure danny can jump in here too
um that was my first actually really
experiential course where i was the
subject of the course and my experience
and
essentially the goal of that class was
to come out at the end of it ready to
launch a search fund and we had three
professors who both are excellent or all
three are excellent practitioners in the
space and then the class was a number of
classmates who were really passionate
about this and ready to hit the ground
running but also in very different
stages some were sort of you know at the
beginning stage of figuring out do i
want to do a search fund and some had
already figured out they want to do it
and had raised capital um i was sort of
closer to the
latter group and i actually had been
working with a fund and we had found a
deal that we wanted to pursue so
i'd been looking at that for three
months before the class started and then
during that class um essentially was
working through the process of selling
the founder to to sell their company to
us and also diligencing the company and
then also just thinking more broadly um
is this an investment thesis i really
want to pursue and am i working with
people that i really want to work with
and it was a fascinating experience
because often we would just bring our
problems to the classroom and we would
just discuss it in open forum
and i remember one of them was that you
know i want i had all these diligence
questions that i wanted to get the
bottom of and i felt that we were taking
too long to ask you know very basic
questions about financials and you would
present that to the class and some of
the feedback i would get was so
enlightening and people would say well
actually the sales process and getting
building a relationship with the seller
is far more important it's not like
private equity where you can say send
these 15 files it really is much more of
an eq exercise versus an iq exercise and
it was so cool to be learning that live
in class and also build an incredible
relationship with my professors who now
have become mentors because they saw me
sort of work through these questions and
so that class was really instrumental in
me kind of learning what does it really
like to pursue a search fund and also
get comfort with doing that after school
awesome
ish and i'm going to ask you at one
question too what i really given your pe
background a specific question we have
15 of our students going into pe another
7 in investment management so in that
whole arena it's really one of the
biggest pathways
i have a great friend in career services
like jessica was talking about so bill
thompson i know his rpe guru and he
usually says if someone's coming from an
eye banking or pe background they have
no problem securing a job but just given
none of you are doing that right out it
might be a big interest do you have any
insights from
friends or others at silver lake or
other firms and and how they were able
to secure jobs
yeah that's not a problem at all i think
there's more jobs than students at psp
in general so
if you want to do pe you can do it i
would also emphasize that i still found
value
in the accounting courses just to like
wrap up and tie
a lot of loose ends you know that maybe
you learned on the job but it's good to
know the academic part of it so that's a
shout out to ron kasnik there on the
accounting side awesome and
the survey courses because in pe you
know you come from a specific style
of private equity
and it's good to see leaders and other
styles or other sizes of deals
and so finance 207 you know was a survey
course i took that was
really helpful for me to see different
styles of investing to find where i
wanted to be even even if that's within
pe there's so many different ways to do
it now will you tell us what to i don't
know what 207 is so i'm really curious
to what when you say survey what do you
mean
i we had different speakers come from
different parts of finance uh and um it
was just amazing you know not only the
students you can talk to and learn from
them but you learn from the speakers
telling their life stories so we had
distressed investing guys we had growth
equity investors
um we had venture capitalists so we were
able to see people at the top of their
field how they thought differently
and that helped me figure out where i
fit in um
that's awesome
all right um
i'm going to start going to
um to some of the questions that are in
our q and a
keeping an eye on the time
so i'll read one from
i think it's michael as international
students are we required to apply to a
specific program if we want to pursue a
career in p.s at a uh us-based firm so
this is a great actual question we have
two internationals on
on the panel today and it comes up a lot
of how much harder is it for
international students to get working
authorization in the states and what how
did if you can speak to you or your
friends how they thought about that
question so danielle you want to start
with that
sure
so
let me if you all know that now the the
gsb has a three-year stem exemption
so we can if we want to stay in the u.s
we can stay up for three years so we
work in stem related fields so that's
that's a huge uh plus
and then it all depends on the firm but
i would say that most
investing uh like that investing firm
they have a good size uh except
internationals um and my friends that
are staying from
latin america that are saying the u.s
and doing investing
they all have their visas
like
like these companies can sponsor their
visas so i think there's
maybe it has to be like a boutique
company that
very very few people maybe they have the
admin or they just you know don't want
to hire international for some reason
but i actually haven't i haven't heard
about it so i would say that for p
a nbc probably most of them will hire
internationals
that's great anything else jessica from
your perspective
yeah so um in my case i was fortunate
enough to get a green card um right when
i started school so i wasn't subject to
the um to sort of h1b international
rules but i was when i was at yale um
and i think the h1b
honestly like again like i i think a lot
a lot of the bigger companies will
sponsor an h1b but as daniel said there
are many um there are many smaller
boutiques that are starting to
understand each one be better i think
the big
problem a lot of times with the h1b when
you first graduate college so not for
not for business school when you first
graduate college is that you're in the
regular pool the regular pool is a much
lower chance of you getting the h1b
lottery once you finish your master's is
actually so much easier to get the
lottery because you you double dip until
you have a priority just for masters and
then you double dip because you can also
be eligible for
for the for the post college sort of
the just bachelor's lottery and because
the gsb gives the the stem extension for
three years that means you're eligible
basically after your opt for like yeah
you know every three year every year
over the three years so it's it's it's
much easier to stay and i think
as long as you're able to communicate
that to companies companies then feel
totally fine spending the
basically the investment to get you to
stay in in the us because obviously like
you're just beers so they want to keep
you here
awesome the next question i want to is
from enrique talk about because i bet a
bunch of folks in the audience have this
question as well he was saying that
starting a fintech company requires many
skills and we do know that as i said
about a third of folks coming in with
finance backgrounds end up going into
operating roles so the question is how
does the gsb ho program help you with
these other
skills tech product management legal you
know what it's like to be an
entrepreneur so i'm going to look back
to ishin because i know you founded your
own company and have you know what it
takes on both sides you have them both
in your career and maybe you can speak
to that
yeah and i've invested in a lot of
fintechs too so i can talk a bit about
that but um
it all comes down to the people skills
building a company is just a group of
people that believe the same thing and
it's those core skills at gsp that you
get to practice you don't just learn
from a textbook
starting in the first quarter that will
be the most useful in starting a company
in my mind
and the idea i mean the idea will change
most likely
but you know
working that through with your
classmates pitching them there's even
student vc funds that you can pitch and
get your ideas vetted from that's
that's really valuable um but i would
say
first and foremost is practicing finding
co-founders practicing what your pitch
is
building a team
and figuring out what your mission is
which are all non-finance related things
are important for starting any company
and um that's a great segue ish in many
of our classes like startup garage or
george you talk about startup search
fund but startup garage or
design for extreme affordability any of
those classes have the student become
again the protagonist to actually create
a company anybody take one of those
outside of georgie's class and talk
about what that's like
anybody here did startup garage
no
maybe i'll say a moment because all
those things and you were saying i know
you've done it before because you were
the entrepreneur but a group of about 46
students will come together in a startup
garage and they'll decide on what's the
problem they want to solve in order to
graduate that course the class actually
the final class is what's the prototype
so you really will get very hands-on
figuring out who could be my co-founder
what's the problem we want to solve and
how do we actually deliver a product
that will do that
awesome let's go to the next is there
anybody else who
thinks about how you get entrepreneurial
skills at stanford or danielle you're
launching and you know you're actually
building companies right now what would
you say
no i would say like
just the
when i think about my gsb experience i
think academics are maybe 20 or 25
i think just the things outside of
academics formal classes that that's
that's what the real experience is i
think
so just
every
every
bbl every launch that you can go to hear
from entrepreneurs here from investors
you're learning there from them
starting there and then just the things
that you can do part time on the side
volunteering part-time work
doing projects with companies
that's where and especially for us
during pandemic that that was huge
so so what i would a little suggestion
to anyone that either wants to have the
investing or entrepreneurial experience
is try to do something on the side
some sort of project and you will be
amazed by
with your stanford email saying you're a
jsp why you're interested in a certain
talk talking to an entrepreneur or a
certain fund or a certain company doing
something with them that's where you
will learn the most and then combining
that experience with your actual classes
that combination is huge and you can and
even working with other clients like we
have i don't know 20 classes that have
already launched their own company some
of them during the the pandemic
um just um
like you you can you can do that you can
you can do do your do your on the side
project and just working working while
starting i think it's uh if you are able
to manage it
i think it's just the best way to to
learn on the go and and put all these
entrepreneurial um um experiences and
for your benefit awesome and i will um
just uh cap what danielle was saying
actually 18 of students launched
companies last year which is amazing so
you're going to be surrounded by role
models who are really interested in that
and i'm poets and quants did an article
that looked back over the last five
graduating classes so just go back over
the last five years and if you look at
the top hundred students from any
business school who launched a company
ours was almost half of the list and we
raised more money than all the other
ones put together like 1.6 billion 1.7
billion and that's just people who are
ishin and danielle and jessica and
georgie's early stage of career plus you
know a couple years so you will be
inspired by the people around you um i
have one more quick question from
charles what are some of the most
effective ways to gain practical
investing experience at the gsb and also
what are some of the avenues available
to students who want to raise money to
start their own fund
so um
i don't know who would like to answer
that ways to get investing experience or
raising money
i can jump in to start off um
so
i would say a good way to get investing
experience is sorry uh is the finance
and investment club and this club um is
a group of people who love investing we
have regular stock pitches or sorry i
was i was the president one of one of
the presidents so we had stock pitches
um we would have an investment committee
where people would pick pitch a stock
and then we would all sort of discuss
pickle um poke holes
and kind of help refine that person's
investment thesis and then we also ran
um a pretty substantial fund i forget
exactly maybe sean you know but i think
it was over three hundred thousand
dollars where we would actually test the
students ideas and so that was a great
way to practice investing get feedback
from your peers and then also get
feedback from the market
um i would also say that sort of ishaan
mentioned this in his comment too there
are a number of ways to get practical
practical experience while you're at
school um given that we're in the heart
of silicon valley and right by san
francisco there are so many people who
are looking to tap into gsb talent and
there are tons of opportunity from
alumni or people in the network to
actually intern during the year or do
part-time work and that's a great way to
learn from an investor and get practical
experience while you're at school
awesome
great now i'm going to turn it back to
the panelists and if you could give
some advice to
you know uh someone who's in the
audience what i say is oftentimes people
tell me it's the dean that i won't get
in i don't know if i should apply and
i'm always like just do it you're never
gonna know unless you put yourself out
there and do the application for first
so for someone who's thinking about
applying maybe even this fall
any tips you would get them and give
them in that process and i'll start with
jessica
yeah for sure um i think very much
underscoring that you should just apply
um
you can always apply again if not but
um
i think i think a couple of things one
is um
like preparing for the gmat obviously is
important but don't go crazy over it i
think that there's so much so much
stress all the time over um the
standardized tests and i i really think
that just i mean like getting to know
kirsten and getting to know sort of the
gsb ethos it's a it's a it's definitely
a school that's focused a lot a lot on
like the holistic student obviously like
not in the admissions but i definitely
felt that when i was doing my interviews
and once i got my admissions letter on
the things that they were focusing on
was not the gmat score i got or my gba
was a lot around my experiences and how
i thought about my vision for for what i
wanted to do
i think the thing that i would
suggest for people to keep in mind is
think think about what the gsb model is
and and what the gsb is trying to do in
terms of the leaders that they want to
nurture and how we want to really like
change organizations change lives change
the world and think about
like very seriously like how you intend
to do that and how you're going to use
your mba to not just further your own
career but also how you really hope to
make an impact in the world and
thinking around that and i think that
really helps you become a lot more
inspired to apply and think about the
impact you want to have if you're not
just worried about oh my god i have to
get like this a gmat score and so i'm
trying to think a little more about the
future and not just the short term like
how do i get through the application
process i think is important
awesome thanks jessica how about you
georgie what would you say
yeah i would definitely echo jessica's
comments and i think what i would say is
the process can be incredibly daunting
but if you
try to make the effort it actually at
least for me was a process of great
self-discovery especially the gsb
application
one thing piece of advice i would give
people is uh often people try to game
the system or feel that there's a
correct answer you have to give and what
i would say is definitely especially for
the gsb app give the answer that is most
authentic to you
um i think that way you put out an
application that you can feel good about
regardless of the outcome and frankly
i'm personally i'm sure you can say it's
probably more of what the gsp wants to
see wants people to be really authentic
and bring themselves and so that's what
i would say sometimes you have to tune
out the noise and put out an application
that you feel is really
true to yourself rather than what you
think you should be or be saying
awesome and i remember georgia you were
a classics major is that right and yeah
so many koreans yeah i remember i
remember your essays and everything yeah
oh wow
but it's not about um presenting this
finance person who's going to you know
was presenting georgie and who georgie
is and what she cares about so it's
great advice how about you ishm what
would you say
yeah i would echo everyone's points but
also add to take the writing portion
seriously try different drafts don't try
to write it in one day
but also don't try to create a shell of
who you think you are
and i think that process of figuring out
hey this reflects who i am
and come back to it and see it again
will help you realize a lot more about
yourself and give you clarity even
before going to any mba program that's
what happened to me
and so the exercise is valuable
but um yeah go ahead ish i was going to
say um is there anything you could talk
speak to because i bet a bunch of folks
are actually starting to write that
essay anything that you concretely did
to help you do some of that you said you
did multiple yeah i did multiple i did
multiple versions so first i tried to
answer the prompt directly and simply i
remember
and then i read it the next day and i
said hey this this sounds like what they
want to hear but doesn't sound like me
so i'm just going to try to change it
and i started using more i statements
and things we learn at gsp but i didn't
know yet
that's great that was valuable and then
um
[Music]
but i wasn't sure if that's how i should
submit a quote-unquote professional
school essay but i just went with it and
now i realize that's probably the best
way to go with it because
you know i was admitted for who i am
basically
and that's what makes leaders unique and
something i learned at gsp is those
parts that make us who we are so letting
yourself show through those through i
statements and giving personal anecdotes
and small stories i think is really
important
um instead of just saying hey this is
who i am and this is why i'm perfect
because nobody's perfect
well said and um we may be a little
different than other schools so i want
you to be careful to do your homework as
you're submitting other schools essays
but at the gsb i can promise you we
don't really care what you say is your
aspiration in terms of whether you're
admitted or not so if you've never been
in finance like jessica and you say i
want to go into venture capital we're
not going to say oh she could never do
it we really believe that if you come to
the gsb with the community and with all
that you'll bring here you will find a
way to meet your aspiration to fulfill
your dreams as they were it may not be
immediately it may be a pivot down the
road but we know you'll get there so
feel free to just speak to what you
really think will be your true north and
and we know that's going to involve
evolve over time but at this point in
time is there something some problem you
want to solve something you care about
something you want to work on
as an aspiration that's really what we
want to know
so danielle how about you
highlight everything has been said i
think
authenticity just is very important and
and just
think how why are you unique like what
makes you unique and we are all unique
so really what makes you unique
versus anyone else that is applying and
normally like
the professional side like
like we all kind of you know go to
companies working companies different
roles but
normally the unique stuff are in the
most on the personal side and that
that's like where i think it where the
more emotions and more and a more
powerful story comes when you kind of
reflect on that why why why more
normally the
the things that has happened to you and
that have impacted in your life
mostly come on those personal or
non-professional things that maybe some
of them are also in the professional
stuff you can maybe compliment but but
just reflecting on really
what what drives you and
what matters most and how you know what
you want to do in the future what are
the things you want to work on or during
this two-year experience
um and just trying to enjoy that process
not seeing it as is an essay i have to
write this is a reflection process
i'm giving the opportunity to reflect
about my life
and why i want to go to this
this is not an mba this is a leadership
and personal development program it's
that opportunity to be more self-aware
and more introspective
to learn from diversity from others
and be able to also support others in
their journeys so
just understanding what the gsb
experience is about which really that's
what makes this school unique this is
not an mba it's a personal leadership
that's what i think is the most unique
thing about this program so once you
read talk with alumni talk with students
read the articles they just repo talk
read about the classes and you
understand those values and you read
about the values and the ethos of the
school and you understand that that's
what makes this school unique
that's where you maybe you start
relaxing and say wow like let's connect
on that and let's see what are the the
things that that connect me to those
things that gsb say they care about
because the values and the things
kirsten talks about in the article she
writes and in the interviews that that
has been published about them that
that's true like that this is it's about
that it's not about that no gmat and gpa
and all this stuff like there's many
people with that and and a lot of those
high grades and stuff don't don't get in
and people like me that got 60 points
below the average or 80 points below the
average in the gmat
got it maybe because
there's a story around like
that's and just to highlight that the
gmat aspect i have so i almost didn't
apply to the gsb almost didn't apply a
lot of my friends didn't apply because
they got lower than i regiments and
that's incredibly sad
uh because this school looks for that
thing that it makes you special and
that's
and your leadership potential and that a
gmat normally it's like a gmat is a
score it's an exam it's not a that
doesn't define your leadership potential
so highlight encourage everyone to
please apply and please be authentic and
just tell your unique story and just
enjoy this
reflection process of going throughout
through this essay awesome
i'm looking we have just two more
minutes um
that was great tips and one thing i
realized we haven't talked a lot about
is directly is the community
so anybody want to speak to what
surprised them most because i always say
we're like a family and people support
you but coming from me i think it's a
little hard to believe at times so you
guys have experienced it but anyone want
to put their hand up and talk about what
surprised them most about becoming part
of this gsb family
don't want to volunteer at once yeah i
can i can take a quick look oh ish
there's your hand thanks
um
i we have a special portal for alumni uh
and so i reached out during my first
year first six months
you know maybe 20 different alumni and i
think the average response was probably
half a day
regardless of role responsibility
function
so the network the community is so
tight-knit it's pretty incredible and
you know as alumni i think we feel an
obligation to support those that are
coming after us
and support the community and i saw that
firsthand i think i'm i'm still about to
see the the benefits and the fruits of
that but
it's really true and i think um you're
right kirsten to say that it has to come
from the students
because i didn't really believe it until
i saw it so
boy awesome anybody else wanna oh
jessica
yeah happy to jump in sort of two two
points that i think are interesting one
is
um so just double click on what yeshuan
said that's a great example i remember
when i got into the gsb and i wanted to
explore korean venture capital i decided
that i was going to go on linkedin and i
searched um
uh general partner plus stanford gsb on
linkedin and i reached out to
approximately 45 people
um
saying that i i had just been admitted
so just video starting in the fall gave
them my background would love to talk to
them for like 20 minutes or get a coffee
whatever they wanted um just to learn a
little more and get to understand bc
imagining of course that maybe five
people would reply to me and so that
would be fine it turns out that every
single one of the 45 people replied and
we're like absolutely i'll meet with you
come for coffee no come to my office it
was really enthusiastic
so i actually ended up taking a week off
for my job because so many people have
replied and were excited to meet me that
i did like a tour of san hill road and
was going to all of these offices into
coffee at koopa and coffee or whatever
because everyone was so excited to talk
to me and i think that that was already
like a very clear
very very clear example of how much the
alums are there for you and how how
tight the gsb community is
i think that's also true like at the gsb
while you're a student um
just the the level of support and love
that exists between all the students so
many people that
you know it say like you had like a
diplo family emergency which happened to
me during school just everyone will rise
up to the occasion and support you and
find ways to help you and show up with
bagels at your house and it's just like
it's really like such an incredible
community
and um it's really like unparalleled to
anything i've ever seen my gsb
classmates are my best friends and i
know they'll be my best friends for life
so i think both on like a personal level
and also on the professional level it's
really a tight-knit community
awesome well that's a great comment to
wrap up on i want to thank you so much
jessica daniel ishan georgie um it's so
fun to see you after reading all of your
applications live on the screen so i
really appreciate your support and for
those of you in the audience thank you
for joining us and good luck if you're
putting in an application we hope to get
to know you better soon have a great day
[Music]